so I'm at this restaurant I'm all ready
to order but the waiter decides to let
me know what the specials are and I'll
have the cheeseburger please yes we have
this theme and today I'll have the
cheeseburger that's kind of what I want
yeah I mean really this guy is making me
question my cheeseburger oh we also have
the mahi-mahi I'll have the cheeseburger
it's got a little bit of a lime juice
freshly squeezed on it's very delicious
can I just get the cheeseburger we also
have a pion seared halibut you just want
the cheeseburger mmm and then one of my
favorites is a tree out wrapped in bacon
with rosemary
it's so
Oh delicious Owens season
I've won she's murder cheeseburger just
wanted she were geez my gosh would you
like to say it's the omen